[Music]
welcome back to science click today the
vacuum in common terms emptiness refers
to the lack of any visible matter we say
for example that a glass is empty from
the moment it does not contain any
liquid in reality from a fundamental
point of view the glass is never truly
empty on the contrary it holds a
gigantic number of air molecules
billions and billions of them which make
up the gas undetectable by the naked eye
but which is a real and concrete sort of
matter to realize certain experiments it
can be beneficial to factor out the air
in our environment whose presence might
be disturbing this is what we call
creating a vacuum to achieve this result
air must effectively be pumped out and
extracted from the object that contains
it in practical terms it remains
impossible to achieve perfect vacuums
however we can get very close thanks to
modern techniques which enable us to
reduce the quantity of particles
thousands of billions of times over
having said this the most extreme vacuum
which can be obtained in the laboratory
is still very far from absolute
emptiness in the best case scenario they
remain a few billion particles per cubic
metre if we want to find a space even
emptier than those we can create in a
lab it is necessary to leave the earth
as atmosphere and travel into space in
the space that exists between planets in
our solar system for example particles
are very rare we can only count a few
dozen million per cubic metre however it
is in intergalactic space meaning space
that exists between galaxies that we
come across almost complete emptiness
with only around one single particle per
cubic meter on average with such a small
matter density we would need to have a
container the size of our entire planet
have as many particles as in a simple
glass of water
in a perfect vacuum with total absence
of matter certain properties which we
take for granted no longer halt firstly
if we tried to play the guitar in a
vacuum it would be impossible to make
any sound as the vibration of the
strings would not be able to travel
through the air to reach our ears more
generally said in the absence of any
form of matter to restitute vibrations
sound cannot travel through empty space
[Music]
moreover at the Earth's surface the
atmosphere exerts a weight with which it
pushes down on the objects it contains
this equates to a colossal amount of
compression force this force corresponds
to the weight of two adult elephants for
each square meter this is what we call
atmospheric pressure if we do not feel
this pressure in our daily lives it is
because our bodies and most objects also
generate an internal pressure directed
towards the exterior which imposes the
atmospheric pressure perfectly let's
consider a plastic bottle in which we
create a vacuum by pumping out the air
it contains now that it is empty the
bottle can no longer resist outside
pressure because it no longer contains
anything it will therefore get violently
compressed by the weight of the
atmosphere finally an empty space does
not really have a temperature indeed
what we call temperature is the degree
to which particles are agitated in a
certain environment in air for instance
it is warmer when air molecules are more
agitated and colder when they are less
agitated but in an empty space in the
absence of particles it is impossible to
measure any agitation level because
there are no particles as such the
concept of temperature loses its meaning
in a vacuum
heat can only be propagated through
lights and other electromagnetic waves
which are the only waves capable of
traveling in empty space
let us now think about the idea of
emptiness not at the human scale but at
the microscopic scale all matter is made
up of atoms an atom is made up of a
nucleus around which electrons orbit the
nucleus is about a hundred thousand
times smaller than the atom in its whole
but it represents by itself 99.9 percent
of the total mass of the atom as such
atoms are made up mostly of empty space
which means that all visible matter in
the universe is also made of empty space
to conclude even the emptiest of spaces
will never be perfectly empty according
to quantum physics the vacuum state is
one constantly filled with a multitude
of virtual particles which perpetually
pop in and out of existence these are
known as vacuum fluctuations a virtual
particle is a particle whose existence
is so short-lived that is completely
impossible for us to observe it indeed
the laws of quantum mechanics say that
it's possible for such particles to
appear out of nothing with the condition
that they disappear very quickly such
that it be impossible to observe them
since virtual particles cannot be
observed they are allowed to possess
some very strange properties which go
against the laws of traditional physics
for example there is the fact that they
can appear out of nothing or that some
can possess a negative energy although
it is impossible to observe them the
existence of these virtual particles
brings about some concrete and
measurable phenomenon these particles
are actually the carriers of the four
fundamental interactions in our universe
for example it is by the exchange of
virtual photons that electrical charges
are able to interact at a distance
these particles also have indirect
effect by the fact that they exert a
certain pressure on objects
they are also involved in what is known
as Hawking's radiation when black holes
evaporate over time as a result of their
strong gravitational pull which converts
virtual particles into ordinary ones
today we think that the quantum energy
contained an empty space could very well
be somewhat similar to dark energy a
famous type of unknown energy which
tends to accelerate the expansion of our
universe however when we compare its
intensity with that of dark energy we
find a number which is 10 thousands of
billions of googles of times too big
this is one of the greatest unsolved
mysteries of modern science what is
known as the vacuum catastrophe
[Music]